[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de votre journal local
voici les titres de ce jeudi 9 mars
la contre attaque de la droite passe par
plaisir et xavier bertrand valérie
pécresse et david douillet notamment
acquis et en réunion publique hier
devant 500 militants une image de
rassemblement
après des jours et des semaines très
compliqué pour la droite et pour
défendre à nouveau le candidat fillon du
vélo 100% féminin pour la journée
internationale des droits des femmes la
deuxième édition de l'événement elle à
vélo était organisée hier au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
toute une soirée pour la promotion du
cyclisme
et si la poésie et s'inviter dans vos
trajets en bus une idée originale devenu
réalité aujourd'hui sur plusieurs lignes
de bus du réseau stibus une initiative
de l'agglomération dans le cadre du 19e
printemps des poètes
mais on débute donc ce journal avec de
la politique et la droite qui souhaite
tourner définitivement la page de la
division et de la fère fillon l'ancien
premier ministre qui a présenté
aujourd'hui lé nouveau nom de son comité
politique pour la suite de la campagne
hier soir à plaisir une réunion publique
est également organisée parmi les élus
présents avec xavier bertrand le
président de la région haute france et
plusieurs députés yvelinois comme david
douillet où jean-marie têtards une image
de rassemblement après plusieurs
semaines plutôt chaotique pour la droite
reportage
la marseillaise en guise de conclusion
d'une réunion publique une habitude en
campagne présidentielle mais les paroles
prennent forcément une signification
particulière après des semaines agitées
pour le camp des républicains au bord de
l'implosion il y a quelques jours la
droite joue désormais la carte du
rassemblement des relais candidats film
tout le monde a conscience que si on
veut réformer notre pays est allé ans
dans le bon sens le seul qui peut à le
faire c'est françois fillon donc de huy
et toute la famille est réunie
on se doit d'être assemblés dans notre
pays voilà parce que si la droite
française n'est pas présente à cette
élection présidentielle
le jeu démocratique le pourra quoi être
fournis pour cette réunion publique
organisée à plaisir et xavier bertrand
et valérie pécresse président de région
notamment défendu le projet françois
fillon sécurité justice lutte contre le
terrorisme des thèmes de la droite dure
qui ont convaincu les 500 militants
présents pour l'occasion
moi j'ai fait un choix pour sauver la
france pour avoir un programme et une
personnes qui sont en adéquation est
absolument aucun ce qui est important
c'est un programme c'est sa personnalité
[Musique]
et puis bon
il ya présomption d'innocence et moi je
pense que c'est à donner tonnes un peu
plus de quarante jours du premier tour
de l'élection présidentielle emmanuel
macron et marine le pen ont été
également les cible de nombreuses
attaques de la part des élus
républicains
les candidats dans marché du front
national qui font désormais la course en
tête dans les sondages devant françois
fillon à saint quentin en yvelines le
vélodrome nationale organisée hier soir
sa deuxième édition de l'événement elle
à vélo une soirée 100% filles est un
moyen pour les participantes de passer
quelques heures entre amis mais aussi
d'être sensibilisés à la pratique du
cyclisme bien être et baptêmes de piste
étaient également au programme
retour sur cette soirée avec mélanie
poké elle les premiers gestes sont
hésitants mais le staff de la fédération
française de cyclisme prodigue des
conseils pour sa deuxième édition elle à
vélo invité à nouveau les femmes au
vélodrome c'est une super idée
ça permet de se retrouver entre filles
passaient aussi un bon moment
c'est une belle façon de célébrer la
journée de la femme et puis on a fait
des jolies découvert notamment le vélo
smoothie qu'on a trouvé très sympa on
fait déjà du vélo un peu de bmx vtt là
c'était l'occasion de faire un baptême
piste j'avais jamais fait baptême donc
que nathalie simon ancienne championne
de planche à voile et animatrice télé à
elle même testé génial chez monter
jusqu'aux
au dessus du bleu en haut à la presse
quant aux et je pensais vraiment pas
quand je les ai vus au tout début je
disais je ne vais jamais y arriver c'est
pas possible tu es un peu en apnée et
vinci et je suis très très très contente
soirée entre filles mais avec un but
bien précis montré que le cyclisme se
conjugue aussi au féminin
c'est la mission que s'est donnée la
fédération actuellement seulement 10 %
des licenciés sont des femmes on voit
que le troisième sport pratiqué par les
femmes à 33 % celle cycliste face et le
le vélo au sens large du terme
toutes les pratiques vtt route ou
d'autres d'aucuns potentiel énorme en
matière de développement et je pense que
l'on va pouvoir monter à 25 % de
licenciés dame au sein de la fédération
c'est une ambition et pour ça on s'est
donné des moyens des outils pour que nos
clubs sont aussi sensibilisés à
l'ensemble des pratiques un kit
pédagogique sera proposé au club dès le
mois de juin pour donner des ailes aux
vélos et toujours dans le cadre de cette
journée internationale des droits des
femmes la ville de magny les hameaux
organise elle une semaine spéciale des
ateliers des cours mais aussi des
rencontres et des débats sont organisés
jusqu'à dimanche
mardi c'était l'association agissez qui
a animé une conférence sur les droits
des femmes lorsque celles ci sont
victimes de violences conjugales
écoutez à ce propos l'animatrice de
cette soirée au micro de miquel et demi
d'euros ben on est quand même passé de
la domination de l'homme total à des
droits de la femme très récent puisque
sa date quand même de
du 20e siècle et le 21 28 unième siècle
est en train de définir encore plus les
choses et de faire des avancées encore
plus pas assez encore spectaculaire mais
voilà on avance très très bien des
avancées positives au niveau des lois
après il reste encore l'application de
la loi
ça c'est en cours dans le reste de
l'actualité locale une opération plutôt
original dans les bus de l'agglomération
dans le cadre de la 19ème édition du
printemps des poètes des artistes ont
sillonné aujourd'hui différentes lignes
du réseau stibus pour déclamer poèmes et
proverbes africains
l'objectif évidemment vivre son trajet
différemment un reportage de mélanie
poquet ils sont prêts à mener leur
embuscade
leur cible c'est passager de la ligne 4
mais pas d'inquiétude cette embuscade
fait partie du printemps des poètes
il vaut la peine d'être vécue même si
elle est détesté la vie vaut la peine
d'être vécue même si elle est méprisé la
vie vaut la peine d'être vécue même si
elle est humiliée ce printemps ce
printemps c'est le terme poèmes
d'afrique et d'ailleurs donc on a failli
tout une collection des problèmes qui
ont touché notre coeur qui nous ont
inspirés qui nous a
nous donner envie de partager donc ça
c'est des poètes africains de tout type
d'afrique du nord les chu de hesse ouest
voilà est d'ailleurs aussi dit il ces
comédiens ne sont pas là par hasard
ils ont la complicité de ski bus c'est
la deuxième année que le réseau les
accueils sur sea line la vie on a
imaginé avec jacques fournier d
itinéraire poétique les embuscades
poétique et ski bus avait tenté l'année
dernière de faire cette expérience et
les clients avaient été plutôt
satisfaits et séduit par cette opération
donc on a voulu renouveler cette année
jeu mais rassurez vous tous les
passagers ont été libérés avec un peu de
poésie dans un coin de la télécharger
ici le soleil fera place à la lune la
lune aux nuages les nuages à la nuit vos
voiles - une carte postale
elle développe et l'emploi sur saint
quentin en yvelines c'est l'objectif
poursuivi par deux associations du
territoire delta ce qui efface yvelines
afin d'améliorer encore leurs actions
elles ont décidé de s'associer à
l'occasion d'un partenariat signé il ya
quelques jours face yvelines qui
recrutent des cadres actifs en charge du
coaching de chômeurs se rapproche un
site de delta ce qui est un groupement
d'une quarantaine de grandes entreprises
où elle compte enrôler ces nouveaux
coaches et pour multiplier les
opportunités
cette dernière crée également un club rh
vous pourront échanger librement et les
recruteurs de ses entreprises membres
écoutez sur ce sujet les présidents des
deux associations au micro de patrick
jacques de dixmude delta regroupe les
grandes entreprises du territoire et
donc les cadres et les gens qui
travaillent dans ces entreprises vont
pouvoir fois coach et des chômeurs de
façon à faire en sorte que il retrouve
du travail
détecté que dans les quartiers il y
avait des jeunes qui avait des talents
qui était très bon scolairement mais qui
malheureusement n'avait pas de réseau
ces jeunes là il faut qu'on leur donne
la possibilité de rentrer dans nos
grands gros des faces yvelines et
l'outil sur le territoire qui peut
permettre aux entreprises d'être plus
efficace sur ce sur ce recrutement dans
le domaine de la diversité la direction
trappe à présent une cérémonie de
citoyenneté était organisée mardi en fin
d'après-midi aussi une cérémonie de
remise des cartes d'électeur le but de
l'événement organisé par la mairie
donner un aspect solennel à
l'acquisition du droit de vote
écoutez à ce propos le maire socialiste
de trappes di malanda au micro de
mélanie poker d'être électeur c est
citoyens de notre république c'est à
dire pouvoir choisir à chaque élection
qu'elle soit locale ou qu'elles soient
d'ordre national pouvoir exprimer ce que
l'on pense par rapport à tel programme
par rapport à telle personne par rapport
aux orientations philosophiques
idéologiques que l'on a et donc c'est
quand même temps le signe extérieur qui
d'une entrée de le dire en
responsabilité
c'est désormais impossible de les rater
les web séries se multiplient sur les
plateformes d'hébergement vidéo des
formats courts réalisés par des
professionnels ou des passionnés
un groupe de saint quentinois a décidé
de lancer leur propre production easter
egg la série a débuté le 22 février et
sera diffusée tous les quinze jours une
découverte de mélanie poquet encore
[Musique]
saurez-vous trouver les histoires agacé
références cachées
les réalisateurs de cette nouvelle web
série sont passionnés de cinéma de manga
ou encore de jeux vidéo
c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de
références de boeuf que j'aime beaucoup
et là de la france à agen c'est pas que
j'aime beaucoup c'est chez moi
tranquille je les ai bien évidemment les
derniers essais du processeur guerre
soit la paléontologie dans les noms des
personnages et plein de références dans
les titres aussi c'est vrai qu'il ya pas
mal de vent un dommage parce qu'on peut
dire ah bah je vais en tout cas
clairement je me suis inspiré de choses
que de trafic d'organes et des
références mais pas seulement
easter egg c'est aussi l'histoire de
deux collègues en compétition six
épisodes de 5 minutes tourné à saint
quentin en yvelines et à fontenay le
fleury
ils sont onze à participer au projet
professionnel ou amateur
[Musique]
voyons ce que bon moment on a fait pas
mal de choses ensemble
moi je suis photographe professionnel
sur fontenay-le-fleury donc j'ai
forcément tout ce qui à l'image du coup
on a parlé de cela je le dis bah écoute
moi aussi je vais faire le tour de ce
que tout ce qui est sage et l'ina et que
vanité qui sont eux qui commandent qui
va aussi du côté des professionnels mais
ce continent a fait plein de projets
elle l'a mise en ligne des épisodes est
prévue toutes les deux semaines
les références tu trouveras fin de ce 7
8 le journal demain place aux 7,8
l'hebdo il sera notamment question des
droits des femmes
d'ici là tous nos reportages sont à
retrouver sur notre site internet tv fil
78 points comme ou l'application tv fils
excellente soirée à tous
[Musique]